Major breaking news as the District of
Columbia just got spanked on the DUPA
with their motion being denied. the
motion to expedite their petition for
reharing on bon in front of the DC court
of appeals in this huge case for us, the
Benson versus United States case, which
of course dispound found specifically
that magazines holding more than 10
rounds are indeed protected by the
Second Amendment and cannot be banned,
thereby creating a huge split of
authority in America among the senior
courts, which of course is historically
a basis for, you guessed it, a grant of
by the United States Supreme court.
Let's break down this big win for the
Second Amendment today and a big loss
for the District of Columbia that went
bye-bye with their motion just now.
Hey folks, I'm Mark Smith, host of the
Forbox and Diner, proud American gown
owner, constitutional attorney, member
of the United States Supreme Court Bar
and proud to say the top voice the
second amendment in America. Thank you
2025 and 2026 gun news awards. All
right, before we talk about this big win
today, thanks to the DC Court of Appeals
in the Benson versus United States case,
I want to remind you all that I'll be
the keynote speaker uh this coming
Friday out there in Arizona for the Gun
Owners of America annual dinner for
activists. So, if you're going to be out
there in Arizona, make sure you swing on
by and say hi. All right, folks. This is
exciting news. The District of Columbia
is clearly panicking. And we know
they're panicking because they filed
kind of a crazy motion to prevent the
decision in Benson versus the United
States, which a couple weeks ago held
that magazines that hold more than 10
rounds are protected arms under the
Second Amendment.
And this was a terrible blow for the
anti-gun movement in America for many
reasons. One of which, of course, is
this was a very, very long 50page plus
detailed analysis to totally consistent
with what I've been teaching here on
four boxes diner about how magazines
that hold more than 10 rounds are not
only textually arms, as in the right of
the people to keep their arms shall not
be infringed, but beyond that, any
attempt to ban them requires the
government to demonstrate that these
magazines that hold more than 10 rounds
are not in common use because it is the
government's burden at the historical
level of the brewin methodology which is
really hell or brewin right it's the
government's burden to show that these
arms are not in common use because the
only way the government can meet its
burden of showing that an arm is
dangerous and unusual is that the
government must show they're dangerous
and unusual and the burden is on the
government which means if the government
cannot show that a particular arm in
this case magazines that hold more than
10 rounds are not in common use by
Americans for lawful purposes they lose.
And of course, there's no way for the
anti-gunners to prove this and meet that
burden because the truth is magazines
that hold more than 10 rounds are
ubiquitous. They're everywhere. And yes,
I'm confident I use the word ubiquitous.
And I'm glad to see everyone is picking
up on it because it's not a word you see
every day. But that is the right word to
describe the number of AR-15s,
semi-automatic rifles, and yes,
magazines that hold more than 10 rounds
in America. because magazines that hold
more than 10 rounds in America, both for
handguns and long guns, are of course
standard capacity magazines, not large
capacity magazines. Nevertheless, what
happened here was as soon as DC got
blown up in support of, don't forget
that the Trump Bondi Janine Piro, US
Attorney for the District Columbia,
filed a critical motion in September of
last year in this case of Benson,
arguing that magazines could not be
banned and that the DC law was
unconstitutional under the Second
Amendment, and that the United States
government would not enforce that law in
DC because it was unconstitutional under
the Second Amendment. That was the
filing in this very case by the Bondi
Trump
Janine Piro Department of Justice and
the government or I should say the court
of appeals the DC court of appeals
agreed as well they should is the right
answer.
So, needless to say, the District of
Columbia itself, the attorneys for DC
freaked out, I suspect, at the urging of
and with phone calls from the
anti-gunners. I don't know that to be
true, but I'm guessing somebody from the
anti-gun movement picked up the PHONE
AND SAYS, "OH MY GOD, WE'RE IN BIG TIME
TROUBLE. WE'VE just created a split of
authority because the DC Court of
Appeals is the highest court in DC."
Which is the equivalent of a state
supreme court deciding a federal
constitutional question inconsistent
with the rest of America. But as you
know the rest of America when it comes
to courts of appeals deciding that arms
are not banned or I should say arm bands
are constitutional and that the second
amendment doesn't protect anything.
We've gone over this game game which is
the only courts of appeals that get to
decide these questions of whether or not
arms ban magazine bans AR-15 bans
semi-automatic rifle bans. The only
courts of appeals at the federal level
that get to decide these kinds of
questions are the exact same courts that
arise from blue states and blue state
politicians. In other words, the same
politicians in New York, in California,
in Washington, in Illinois, in
Massachusetts, in Maryland, the exact
same politicians that pass these laws
that ban guns, ban magazines, ban
AR-15s, and so on, are the same
politicians that pick the judges for
those areas. which is why you never have
an 11th circuit case out of Florida, a
fifth circuit case out of Texas having
to rule on an AR-15 or magazine ban
because there are no bans for there to
be a challenge in the courts of appeals
in those parts of the country because
there's no laws to challenge. And as you
know, unlike legislators, courts cannot
reach out and touch someone. They can
only decide issues that come before them
that are brought before them. And since
there's no AR-15 magazine ban cases
being brought before judges in Texas, in
Louisiana, in Oklahoma, in Florida, and
so on, there's no way for there to be a
split of authority as a general matter
because all the questions about these
Second Amendment issues only arise in
terrible jurisdictions. And of course,
they're going to uniformly rule against
the Second Amendment because that's who
becomes a judge. It's a general matter
in those kinds of places. With that
said, this is why the DC Court of
Appeals decision in our favor is such a
huge blow to the anti-gun movement
creating this split of authority among
major courts. Now, with the DC Court of
Appeals saying the magazines are
protected arms on the Second Amendment
cannot be banned in contrast with like
the First Circuit out of Boston, the
Fourth Circuit out of Maryland and
Virginia, the Ninth Circuit out of San
Francisco, the seventh circuit out of
Chicago, all saying just the opposite.
But that creates the split of authority
that we've been looking for for the
Supreme Court to take up because the
Supreme Court as a general matter should
be viewed not as a court that fixes
errors. Instead, it is a court that sets
the law of the land when there is a
conflict among senior courts. And now
there is. So as a consequence of this,
DC filed this critical motion saying to
the DC court appeals, please enjoin,
please stop, please stay the
presidential nature
of Benson versus the United States.
Don't let this become presidential.
Don't let this become a brick in the
wall. Don't let this Don't let this
become another ruling that the Second
Amendment supporters in America,
including the Trump administration, can
rely upon. and please expedite in a
super super fast way our petition for
reharing on bunk and reverse these guys
before the anti-gunners get messed up
and spanked by the US Supreme Court.
That was essentially the nature the
essence of the panicked motion
to expedite the review at the same time
stop the presidential value of this
Benson case from going into effect. And
I'm happy to report that the DC Court of
Hills just now said no to DC. They said
that they will not stop the presidential
nature of this decision in Benson versus
the United States from going into
effect. And they also said no, we do not
see a basis for running around like a
chicken with her head cut off in a panic
crazy way.
And therefore, we're not going to
expedite, which means speed along the
request for this case to be reheard on
bonk. We're going to take this in the
normal course. Since you filed a
petition, we the DC court appeals are
inviting Donald Trump, Pam Bonnie, and
Janine Purel to submit a brief as to
whether or not we should grant onbunk
review. And of course, Mr. Ben's
attorney is more than welcome uh to file
an opposition as well, which I'm sure
they will. So this is very good news
because it is clearly signaling that the
DC Court of Appeals is going to make
this decision whether or not to take the
extraordinary step which they almost
never do and rehear this case on bunk
because remember it was a three judge
panel that found these magazines are
protected arms under the second
amendment and for them to be asked to do
an onbunk review which they basically
only do one a year and they're
inevitably in these kind of criminal
cases dealing with like I said jury
selection or some issue with vadier or
some technical criminal trial issue. Uh
they don't really get involved and
onbought these huge you know
constitutional questions that you might
see at the US court appeals level or the
US Supreme Court. So I'm not surprised
that they denied the DC motion to
expedite this or hearing on bond and to
stop this case from being presidential
at least in the short term. So let's see
what exactly Mr. Benson's lawyer argued
that ultimately prevailed. And
basically, it seems to me the DC Court
of Appeals bought into these arguments
brought and advanced by Mr. Benson's a
lawyer. First of all, Mr. Benson's
attorney argued exactly this to the DC
Court of Appeals, which obviously the DC
Court of Appeals agreed with. Let's
check it out. Appellant Tyrie Benson
through council respectfully opposed the
District of Columbia's motion for
expedited treatment of its petition for
re-haring on Bon as explained below. And
in Mr. Benson's opposition to the
district's emergency motion to suspend
the presidential status of the
division's opinion. The District of
Columbia's claim reasons for immediate
action in this case are hyperbolic are
hyperbolic and within the district's own
control. That was a great start from Mr.
Benson's lawyer. Then he goes on to
basically say that this request to
expedite the reharing on bond petition
and to prevent this case from going into
effect as a precedent. Remember as a
precedent we talked about this. They're
basically saying we don't want the
second amendment Trump supporters in
America to be able to use this Benson
decision as another brick in the wall to
support the Second Amendment andor as a
precedent to demonstrate the split of
authority in the United States which
will give rise to basically a Supreme
Court case which of course we want
because if the court takes these cases I
don't see how we lose. We just need the
Supreme Court to take these AR-15
semi-automatic rifle cases and the
magazine cases. And again, I think
there's 0% chance we lose the
semi-automatic rifle case. And I think
there's only about a 2% chance we lose
the magazine case, but I do think that's
a little bit more complicated than the
rifle cases. Uh, but not dramatically.
So, I think we should win both. But with
that said, here's the other point that
Mr. Benson made and successfully made to
the DC court of bills because DC
basically bought into this because they
denied the motion by the District of
Columbia in favor of Mr. Benson. Let's
check out the next point they made
saying that the DC motion is absurd.
Check it out. The District of Columbia
first posits that the court's
invalidation of the district's ban on
large capacity magazines or what this
court calls 11 plus magazines opens the
floodgates for such magazines to surge
into the district creating immediate and
severe risk to public safety that
require immediate action by the onbound
court. But if ceasing enforcement of
this law would truly prompt an immediate
surge of 11 plus magazines into the
district, that surge should have
happened six months ago when the United
States, i.e. the Trump administration,
ceased enforcing this magazine ban based
on its view that the statute is
unconstitutional,
citing to the Janine Piro Pam Bonnie
motion to vacate. Then Mr. Benson goes
on to say,
"And yet no public safety crisis has
emerged and the time." That's right. Why
is that? It's because 11 plus magazines
are in common and ubiquitous use by
law-abiding citizens across this
country, accounting for about half of
the magazines in the hands of our
citizenry, and perfectly lawful in the
vast majority of states. The non-
enforcement and invalidation of this DC
law simply brings the District of
Columbia in line with Virginia and the
37 other states that do not regulate
magazine capacity at all. Hardly any
cause for panic. Well, that's exactly
right. Again, what was happening was
DC's arguing was you have to take away
the presidential value of this Benson
case. Do not let the Second Amendment
movement or Mr. or Benson or anyone use
this decision as presidential value. we
want this case to be reheard on bon and
we want to expedite that and we don't
want this to be presidential but the DC
court of appeals is obviously not
playing along with this game and they
said no we're not going to you know you
can make your petition for rehair and
onbach you're legally allowed to do so
and you've done so but we're not going
to expedite it we're not going to treat
this case in any kind of a special way
which we don't see a basis for it we're
not going to like speed it along we're
not going to deny the presidential value
of the decision it is what it is it's a
precedent for And if you know we change
our minds down the road, well that's
just the normal course of litigation.
But right now there doesn't seem to be
any indication that that's going to
occur. And by the way, it's very
interesting for those of you out in
California. One of the big things that
DC was arguing against this decision in
favor of the second amendment was that
when there was that freedom week or
whatever it was in California when Judge
Bonitz basically enjoined the magazine
restrictions of California, there was a
flood of magazines into the state. And
basically Mr. Benson's lawyer says,
"Well, that's a bunch of hoie because if
this was going to occur, it already be
occurring and it has nothing to do with
this decision." Here's what he had to
say, specifically addressing that
question of flooding of freedom, right?
Flooding freedom into DC, analogous to
what supposedly happened out in
California. Check it out. Given that the
United States is the prosecutorial
authority primarily responsible for
enforcing the District of Columbia's ban
on large capacity magazines, if you
will, and given that his policy of no
longer enforcing the ban does not depend
on the court's decision in this case,
and indeed predated the decision, any
floodgates will remain open. Regardless
of how and when this court resolves the
district's petition for reharing on bonk
goes on to say the District of Columbia
cites no evidence of any surge of these
11 plus magazines into the district and
instead relies on claims by gun owners
groups that more than a million
high-capacity magazine i.e.
high-capacity ammunition magazines
flooded into California during a
one-week window after a federal court
enjoined the state's ban on such
magazines. claims that the gun control
advocates described as inflated and
self-s serving. Goes on to say, "Nor
does the District of Columbia claim here
or cite any evidence that California
experienced a spike in gun violence
after the state was flooded with more
than a million large capacity magazines.
Powerful stuff. Basically, they again
calling to task the District of
Columbia. Mr. Benson's lawyer is saying,
"Look, the burden is on DC to show all
this craziness to prove all this stuff.
They've done nada, nothing. Zippo, their
references to California is very
speculative." And of course, it already
would have occurred because in September
of 2025, many months ago, Janine Piro,
Harmy Dylan, Pam Bonnie, Donald Trump's
Department of Justice already said that
because the magazine ban of more than
magazines of holding more than 10
rounds, that ban in DC was
unconstitutional in their view under the
Second Amendment, they're not going to
enforce it. So any claim that there's
going to be a flood of magazines into DC
would already have occurred. So it's not
unique to this decision. So why expedite
a decision to overturn it? Moreover,
another point that Mr. Benson made,
which presumably the DC Court of Appeals
accepted, was that the DC City Council
has been aware of these issues with
their law since at least September.
They've been aware of this for the last
couple weeks, haven't lost this case.
And the DC City Council, which is
basically DC's legislature, the kind of
DC's Congress, if you will, has done
nothing about this. So Mr. Mr. Benson's
lawyer makes the excellent point to say
if the DC city council WAS SO FREAKED
OUT about a public emergency involving
this court decision andor the Trump
administration's view that the existing
statute is unconstitutional under the
second amendment then certainly the DC
city council would have done something
about it and instead they sat on their
hands and did nothing and in this case
silence and inaction speaks volumes and
obviously the DC court of appeals agreed
with Mr. Benson's arguments on this
front because they simply denied in its
entirety the various requests made by
the District of Columbia which means
that that Benson versus the United
States case right here and right now
that president remains the president and
the law of the District of Columbia and
again what's going to happen now is the
petition for reharbon which basically is
asking the DC court appeals to take all
of the active judges not just the three
that heard the case initially for all
the active judges to hear this case and
make a decision. I'm not sure that's
going to happen because frankly if I sat
on the DC court of appeals I'm not sure
I'd want to get crossways with the Trump
department of justice on this because I
presume the Trump DOJ is going to file a
opposition brief saying there's no need
to grant reharing on this is not an
extraordinary situation they just don't
like it if they don't like it tell the
DC lawyers to seek sir to the US Supreme
Court if they don't like it but that is
the dilemma the DC faces now if you
think about it if the DC court appeals
denies rehearing on bonk what will the
lawyers for DC do? What would their
choice be? They can either take their
ball and go home having suffered this
terrible loss and having an established
press that says magazines that hold more
than 10 rounds or protected arms in the
second amendment cannot be banned or
will they roll the dice and seek cert to
the US Supreme Court and heaven forbid
from the anti-gun perspective the
Supreme Court grant cert on the grounds
of a split of authority and rules for
the second amendment. meaning that the
Benson case will not just be the law of
the District of Columbia, it will become
the law of all of America. All right,
folks. Hope you enjoyed this uh breaking
news episode. Make sure you follow me
over there on X4box Diner. And don't
forget to subscribe the YouTube and the
Rumble. And I'll talk to all of you
again real soon here at the Forbox
Diner. Orders up. Table 2A.